[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys very careful here we go
david so hey
hey what the [ __ ] is careful boys we're
talking you never know
what care boys is the sensation of
sweeping the nation
that's our tagline we rebranded we don't
want to get sensation all the nations
we're super careful now oh [ __ ]
that's my baby
boy
you're making me so nervous while you're
eating because you're choking
careful boy
the egg roll dude the coffee was a new
thing is that you guys [ __ ] yeah well
yeah yeah
yeah steve just kind of
i don't know how do we talk we it was on
here when we made it i was just pointing
out how off the record doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense because we're the most
character
on off the record we're not really off
the record at all we're actually the
most public on off the record we used to
be off the record on patreon we're more
off the record so i was like why the
[ __ ] do we call this off the record
making no goddamn were you here when we
when we changed it to off the record yes
right and then we don't [ __ ] do that
no more because we're so careful and
then careful boys i just don't synergy
being careful at all yeah that's not
really your branding we always talk
about this it's like how the pendulum
always swings too far this way and if
you go too far here it's going to go
[ __ ] there yeah and it's starting to
happen now where i think everybody's so
sick of everybody being so politically
correct they're going to go this [ __ ]
way now that's why it's a joke because
we say we're careful boys but we're
actually getting worse which is awesome
i showed a video of a baby getting
punted earlier yeah nice
which is what our channel is that's what
our channel got a strike for for real
because the baby got kicked yeah baby's
going to kick that's real life though
that's why we had to go to patreon man
but that one was a chinese baby this was
a white baby
you can't have a white baby
yeah
because they don't want minorities
getting kicked right now that's right
but white babies are okay hawaii i saw
this dude in hawaii
we all saw this dude in hawaii
i never knew how much another male liked
me until this guy met me in hawaii were
you talking about he approached me as if
i was the finest [ __ ] on the island and
you was the one
that was working it re-enacted it
i'll say this
i walk over the hill and i just see a
pair of buns just chilling on the beach
and he's looking off on the water and
he's laying out there
yeah i see some see some nice luscious
malasadas his wife is literally the
funniest person i've ever met him really
she'd be talking [ __ ] he doesn't talk
about his wife he doesn't talk about
himself he's talking about anything
about himself what do you want me to do
you have to come here and talk about me
all the time that's not what it's about
it's about careful boys dude watch she
comes over here and crushes it better
than nick i guarantee she will she would
bro so subtly funny so i'm we're
chilling right and we were meeting him
at sunset beach and then she looks at me
because she's real sad and she goes you
know
nick is so excited to see you
[Laughter]
she's so happy this goes like yo what
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was like i was like what are you
talking about not having your person's
back at all it was like she's always
burning this floor you know what it is
though she likes burning me in front of
david because she knows david is gonna
[ __ ] set me on fire that's what she
likes about it as she's saying it i look
at him and i see the happy energy just
shaking off of him but i'm like bro you
want to [ __ ] me or what guy like relax
on that same topic a shout out to uh
gilbert you're being the fattest [ __ ]
person i know
and not knowing what food is you fat
[ __ ] what did he do he recommended all
these restaurants and for a fat person
the worst restaurants on the island
all you do is shove food in your [ __ ]
face but you don't taste it he was here
earlier too i should have [ __ ]
roasted his ass
so everything was tasteless it's just
the worst restaurant
he told us to go to some pokey place
which by the way isn't a transplant town
not even [ __ ] locals a trans town
de chapelle is not allowed there
it's a straight transplant town right he
only drinks 13 dollar coffee too yeah he
does i thought he was gonna know what
the [ __ ] around you know what gilbert is
dude gilbert's the guy that if you put
three [ __ ] wines in front of him and
they're all [ __ ] he'll be like this one
here is so much better
[ __ ] it's about the confidence david he
needs to say gilbert eat food it just
goes in his mouth doesn't chew go
straight down
it wasn't true he doesn't chew he does
not chew that much though no he just
opened up about how he used to be
[ __ ] fat as [ __ ] you know what they
used to call him in high school it's
called triplex fatty.com
that's crazy bro
and he called his bomb back they didn't
even have those kinds of websites when
we were kids we just called them fatties
that's the longest nickname i've ever
heard of my life and the fact that he
let somebody finish that sentence before
he interrupted them they made high
school skits about how fat he was in
high school bro they did skits about
them too performance and they killed
dude everybody loved it by the way
triple x fatty is kind of a double funny
because it's triple x like the size and
also triple x like the porn it's really
smart the kids were burning him were
funny yeah
we should get him on the show dude who
got him laughing when he was about to
cry
hillary if you were one of gilbert's old
bullies please message us we'll bring
you guys yeah yeah if you guys know who
he
is
and you can roast them again open invite
anytime you want you know a lot of the
fat kids that got bullied when i was
younger they were also big though so fat
people were bullying fat people no they
were like tall so big that if you were
making fun of them they could they would
also have to run away from them because
they grabbed you they would [ __ ] you up
because they were huge you know so you
just had to make fun of them from a
[ __ ] distance so everybody would just
yell at me all the way across the room
you fat [ __ ] you're like bro if i was
skinny i'd catch you dude i'd do it if i
was wearing flip-flops right now i know
this wasn't my choice
as always you were fat all your life
though i remember seeing your [ __ ]
home pictures and you and your brother
standing around like you're chubby but
you weren't like i got really fat i got
really really fat in college because to
be honest with you what happened was
mcdonald's oh wait did you know about
mcdonald's beforehand so my family we
didn't like to eat a lot of fast food
like my parents just wouldn't it was
white delight that's what i used to call
it because all the [ __ ] white kids
would get they would get the the wonder
bread the ham and cheese sandwich i
never [ __ ] got that [ __ ] i never got
to really eat uh mcdonald's uh
occasionally burger king and sometimes
long john silvers so
but i like that you complain you didn't
get a ham and cheese sandwich you had no
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is the most boring
[ __ ] ever no no no steve when you
[ __ ] bite that [ __ ] sandwich and it
sticks to the top of your mouth
yeah
peel it off with it we weren't allowed
to have no
mayonnaise and it comes out kind of
tangy a little bit in there did your mom
used to get the [ __ ] roman wheat
bread [ __ ] yes why i hated that i
was like can't we just get some [ __ ]
wonder bread we always got wheat bread
too growing up my mom would [ __ ] hand
make sushi at the house i would throw it
in the [ __ ] garbage can and i would
get that wonder bread and i roll it up
with just ham cheese and like this and
oh you roll
yo somebody call the chef real quick
compliments to the chef which is all the
stuff that we couldn't eat when we were
younger because i think all the kids had
it so it made me [ __ ] want it yeah
and then when i brought my food my dad
was like don't breathe they're going to
make fun of you i'm like why
why are you telling you not to break up
they're going to call you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] cheeky [ __ ]
your dad's dope bro that's funny
he's very aware yeah and i remember
watching uh kids eat lunchables yo yeah
yo so what my [ __ ] parents did is
like so they got lunchables on sale
right because their biggest thing was
the price and so they got it on sale and
then after they had it on sale
my
they
would repack like ritz crackers and [ __ ]
at the same time
again and i'd be like that's not the
same that's not good because i need that
like shitty ham that's like came out of
a tube or whatever you know what's
[ __ ] disgusting that i used to think
was fire lunchables
i don't even know they made one no they
do you could assemble it it's like cold
bagel bread yeah it's not even bagel
bread i was reminiscing on it because
what's her face [ __ ] gina put it on
her stories and she goes you guys don't
know about this [ __ ] and she was eating
it like oh
so
just like with her piggy i'm like okay i
remember this being fire when i was a
kid too went to a [ __ ] van picked one
up
into it and i [ __ ] almost yak it was
that bad not good at all it's it's like
raw dough yeah and then and it's cold
it's like cold cold
yeah yeah and it's the worst tomato
sauce ever i don't even know what kind
of bread that is what do they feed our
children that's the perfect example of
when you're a kid
you just have stars in your eyes
i'm eating pizza at lunch and it's like
and i made it
it looks like pizza so you're like i'm
eating pizza well you know what you're
in it for though is for the [ __ ]
snickers bar in there that's what you're
in it for it is that little piece we
didn't have a snickers bar back in the
day bro you're [ __ ] young
they didn't have like a candy in there
no they only had they had one single
[ __ ] cracker and then sauce
that's it and they would upgrade later
on they had the pepperoni one oh yeah
see that's when i grew up here it was
the pepperoni and i was super happy when
i got it and i just i ate it again and
it's not good one thing that's still
good though
capri science capricorn buddy
sorry
stabbing it through the bag and then
being completely [ __ ] up oh cause you
didn't do it right yeah i never could do
it right and you had to do it upside
down did you ever get it where you
[ __ ] cause you know how there's like
an inner pouch where you like pushed it
in and it missed both pouches yeah and
you're just like trying to suck like why
the [ __ ] does it work
you're too strong for your own good dude
today's video is brought to you by
upstart it's nearly thanksgiving and if
you guys are in debt let me give you
guys something to be grateful for upstar
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether you're paying off credit
cards or consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment upstart
knows that you're more than just your
credit score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart uses your income and current
employment to help you find a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans between 1000 to fifty
thousand dollars and receive your funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payment
today by going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record and don't forget to use
the url so they know that we sent you
guys your loan amounts will be
determined by the credit income and
certain other information that you
provide on the loan application go to
upstart.com off the record
what were your favorite [ __ ] uh kid
snacks
turtle pies remember hold on a second
ninja turtle pie [ __ ]
continue to elaborate oh you may like
those regular pocket pies but it's green
ooze yeah yeah yeah is that like the
stator brothers exclusive
oh no no it's like those regular pies
those pocket pockets it was another
sensational sweeping it's like it's a
it's a pocket pie but inside it's green
ooze no i don't i don't know what you're
talking about dude
had one of these as a kid you could go
to the liquor store get one right now is
it like is it like a little debbie like
it's like a small pie never had that
i've never had it's like wax paper pie
i've had wax paper pie but not turtle
pie i forgot they're called this
[ __ ] i feel like a dollar i know
what you're talking about oh my god that
looks radioactive i've never had that
[ __ ] of course oh it's by hostess too
wait what what's the
vanilla pudding inside it's like custard
and the turtles ate it on the show
it's like there's a special episode
where they're eating my favorite [ __ ]
was the uh government like cherry pie
the uh what do you call that [ __ ] oh bro
you know which one i'm talking about it
has like real footprints it looks like
that yeah but that one's like a dollar
each right it's like hanging on a rack
oh bro i gotta go get some dude crazy
man some of them have real fruit man
that [ __ ] looks like that's real paint
[Laughter]
you never had colored icing you cynical
[ __ ]
you should look like the paint they put
on anti-coolers
oh do you guys remember ecto cooler yeah
oh yeah the high ceiling ic right yeah
yeah what was that level the
ghostbusters collapse or squeeze it's
you guys remember squeezits
it's a plastic tube and you open like
this and you squeeze these suppose i
love squeeze it i think that was just an
iv bag
wait it's a bag or is it a it's no no
it's it's a plastic waxy thing you twist
off the top yeah it's yeah when was the
first time you guys tried a honey bun oh
honey until i was like a teenager to be
honest i was in high school actually you
got honey buns that's that hood snack
yeah it's like a cinnamon roll but like
you know that's [ __ ] good yeah orbit
you guys remember that drink yeah the
little bb balls in there that company
went down there somebody choked on it
and died or something
so we could never have it again how do
you choke on an orbit i don't know i
think like a kid died from it it's like
little boba balls inside [ __ ] loser
ass four-year-old yeah squeeze it
squeeze it baby yeah yeah i do i do you
remember the board it's radioactive
that's the goal of the plastic don't
they do that with kool-aid
now they have the pops dude i think
kool-aid bought them out or some [ __ ]
they just took their technology called
kool-aid birds
sunny d was the [ __ ] too
sunny for gushers
favorite part was getting gushers where
they all melt together one giant gusher
that you pull out kool-aid bursts right
now kool-aid radioactive edition
apparently oh yeah
it's like bright colors the biggest
thing in seventh grade was when
everybody figured out or it was that
thing that yellow seven gives you like
smaller balls where it makes your sperm
come on remember yellow five yellow
flowers mountain dew yeah i just added
two [ __ ] numbers to it yellow seven
baby but
i i don't even know how that rumor
started but because it's not real right
it's all misinformation well because
they had yellow seven and [ __ ] hot
cheetos or yellow five i'm sorry was it
yellow five yellow yellow thirteen and
so they they had in hot cheetos they had
it in everything but at that time nobody
was drinking mountain dew and i bet you
mountain dew was [ __ ] pissed yeah
because when that rumor came out nobody
drink that [ __ ] and it was the most
caffeinated soda that you could get i
stopped drinking mountain dew you guys
remember like suicide where you like get
ice and you go every single drink but
then you skip mountain dew too because i
wanna i'll dive i don't wanna keep
they can't get any smaller you guys
remember this one dude surge
oh okay wait do you remember vault yeah
was the same it was the same always like
the re-ready like cooler surge or
whatever drink a lot of that the dopest
things is when you go to another country
and you get to try their versions of the
drinks that you like yup yup like japan
had clear pepsi yeah
chris i don't know what the [ __ ] that
was they don't have that here anymore i
don't remember but it was my favorite
drink they released it a couple years
ago crystal pepsi did we talk about this
doesn't it taste just like regular pepsi
yeah just without the coloring and you
know what's weird if you get apple juice
in taiwan it's just like apple cider
like has bubbles in it you can't get a
flat pan right yeah it's weird your hand
is so good it's yellow is it like the
yellow can like apple syrup yeah i love
apple cider that's good only just apple
cider vinegar if you guys ever get to go
to taiwan and you meet jason chen you'll
understand why he dresses so bad like
that
wait you're telling me you think jason
chen has bad fashion i think jason chen
dresses like doug the cartoon he has he
has one black v-neck that he cycles
through 86 days throughout the year but
he gets a good deal on it though of
course for new people who the [ __ ] is
this jason shannon jason chen find a
picture of him jason chen is a homie of
ours he's about 4 foot eleven he's a
youtube singing sensation he's five
three dog five three he got hands of
steel now
nick the ear has been training him at
boxing and he's actually helped him out
quite a bit because when i first saw him
he was a piece of [ __ ] but now he's
looking for a man he has a voice of an
angel he does look at these guys ears
right here yeah he's not a great he's
trying to steal my brand new that's a
peanut tick tock with his girlfriend
this is actually jason chen when he was
13.
and he still looks the same now that's a
35 year old that's a baby the
traditional taiwanese look is like an
asian vampire though
we're just super pale and pale in
v-necks there's no reason to care about
fashion in taiwan because it's so hot
and [ __ ] humid what's the point they
still wear scarves and [ __ ] in the
winter that's crazy they wear scarves
and it's like 100 degrees outside north
face [ __ ] like [ __ ] bubble jacket at
that point it's the flex right it's like
i don't know it's hot as [ __ ] two years
because they like acclimate to how
[ __ ] hot it is so if it's like 60
degrees they're like it's [ __ ] cold i
mean that's california it's like l.a
that's la we're just like oh it's chili
50 here right now [ __ ] that's the first
thing i noticed when i when i first lost
like an absorbent amount of weight was
that i started to shiver oh really
you're like a chihuahua now you've never
done that before i i think i have i
don't remember doing it in so [ __ ]
long that when i lost the weight i was
shivering and i didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was whoa why am i moving
involuntary when we were in japan this
full i'm talking about it was like 20
degrees outside t-shirt and that's all
he was wearing yeah i know i don't
[ __ ] understand that why are you
disappointed
we were at the base of mount fuji and
this one had a t-shirt on i'm surprised
he wasn't shirtless in his underwear
have mountain fuji just smelly japanese
women underwear
just like really walking around and then
he just takes off his shirt because he
just can't handle it anymore for some
reason
he's too hot to unleash his muscles
his muscles are like because this piece
of fabric
he's holding him down
if you see like photos that i took
everybody's dying of hypothermia and
bart's sweating
he runs hot huh we're walking around too
much dude you're in the bus bro what are
you talking about from the bus to the
ice cream store it was kind of uphill a
little bit we're not even married to him
and he's already the biggest pain in our
ass
imagine what the [ __ ] that's like poor
geo dude good lord
he shows up out of nowhere with seven
nosebleeds oh my
[Music]
and you know his videos on you can
expect it there'll be a half a roll of
paper towel every time dude there was
one jubilee meeting just because i
didn't want to be alone i just stuck a
piece of paper
i was like why did you always get bloody
noses right before a meeting you get
nervous no i don't maybe i take a shower
and the shower is hot so it starts like
bleeding or i don't know is that a thing
yeah when it gets when i take hot
showers it's like moisturizing right
because it's like steamy and like what
is your blood pressure blood pressure
have you seen a doctor about it yeah
they say like so you can get it from hot
showers because it raises blood pressure
but you could also get it from uh if
it's too cold because it remember it's
thin so it could happen literally any
time
any temperature
i don't know but like my cousin gets it
too people
what i'm supposed to do is get a
cauterize where they like burn like a
like a scar so it gets thick so the
membranes are thinking of scar tissue
then it stops bleeding also which is a
membrane issue yeah how did that is it
genetic or it's gotta be jeanette my
cousin has it too taiwanese dude
taiwanese knows you guys family photos
everybody with one hand
family dude you know what's funny is
that you i could get the two so for me
my dad's passed on the wrong jeep you
guys taiwanese and i can't smell out of
one of my noses how many people got
[ __ ] up noses huh ever since you were
a kid you couldn't smell it my dad would
take me to the [ __ ] chee doctor as a
kid
don't ask me what that is because i
can't say that's why it didn't work yeah
dude well he would just do this
in hopes of helping me to clear clear up
my nose and even as an eight-year-old
i'm like i don't know if he's gonna do
it dad oh how can you tell that it's
only from one nose because it's like
i can breathe out here oh so you can
just breathe oh [ __ ] it's stuck in there
like it's not from the fighting no since
i was a small child a wee lad so it's a
taiwanese membrane what's in there my
membrane's too thick i need to give some
membrane in the [ __ ] part you got to
fix your cheek bro
you got to unlock your [ __ ] chakra
bro your nose chakra's all blocked up do
you guys believe in that type of eastern
medicine a thousand percent to an extent
and you know it's crazy you know what's
crazy though like you would do it and i
was skeptical and my mom would always be
like what the [ __ ] you going over there
all the time but when he would do his
hand i would feel like warm and like
tingling because you would see his other
head he was jacking you up
he was like crazy
that'll work my dad's in the room like
yeah that's the cheek
that's the chi working right there yeah
i was like oh he did that to me last
week that's the move mario went to that
one [ __ ] chi doctor you know that
[ __ ] guy wow let me tell you what let
me tell you about this guy right you
want to talk about the biggest [ __ ]
scam artist i've ever met in my name his
name is [ __ ] me [ __ ] all right i
don't know his name but
so mariel she's also very skeptical
right and then she always likes to give
people the benefit down she's a little
loopy or something
if mario looks at this guy and says he's
weird he's [ __ ] weird she said this
is what he did he goes
lift your arm up please
so what happened with your grandmother
are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
mario goes
nothing he goes are you sure he goes i'm
pretty sure there's nothing happening
with my grandmother she goes oh it's not
your grandmother it's your grandmother's
grandpa wait did did he just grab
muriel's titties no it's like the upper
what was your grandmother
[Laughter]
but his rationale is saying that like
family trauma things that you know what
did anything happen
no nothing the [ __ ] that causes muscle
imbalance how do you know what happened
to her grandma you don't know
the funniest thing is that after he was
doing the whole grandmother stuff right
i looked at her after i was like so what
did he say after he goes we have to
figure out what went wrong with your
grandmother i was like so wait hold on a
second he's not going to fix your
problems but he's going to fix the
problems of somebody who died like 40
years ago [ __ ] this guy this guy thinks
he's in a horror movie it's like the
ring and he's like we gotta solve the
curse so that she can rest
but it's the same thing too everything
that this guy does he always gives a
general explanation of what's happening
because what's the number one thing that
these guys always say
is getting rid of what out of your body
toxins
yes what are the toxins sir they can't
tell you you don't they don't know what
the toxins are getting anti-radicals in
your [ __ ] bloodstream that are
[ __ ] up your yeah you're you're uh
it's too bad we don't have our shoemaker
here to confirm what he just said
[Music]
you